Congratulations, you successfully
completed your master resume.
You now have an index sheet of all
of your professional experience.
Now, you are ready to begin
crafting a targeted resume.
In this phase of the lesson,
envision yourself as a cook.
Your master resume is your pantry full
of good ingredients and now you need to
use these items to make a targeted
resume, much like you would a good meal.
Because even the best ingredients can
still make a bad meal, you want to
keep in mind moderation, planning, and
tactfulness in this creative endeavor.
Just like a cook gets to be creative in
what ingredients to use to make a meal,
you'll also get to be selective when
you decide on what elements to include
in your resume.
Let's get cooking.